las gráficas de una función lineal fx
igual a mx más bien y de una función
exponencial gtx igual a por efe elevado
a la x donde r es mayor que ser o pasan
por dos puntos menos 19 y 1.1 ambas
gráficas se muestran a continuación y
bueno puedes ver claramente que esta es
la función lineal y esta otra es la
función exponencial podemos ver que la
función exponencial de crecer mientras x
es cada vez más grande esto es una buena
pista para pensar que r la cual sabemos
que es mejor que cero será un número
entre 0 y 1 y por ende gdx se aproxima a
cero mientras x que se escribe la
ecuación para cada función
ahora usemos estos dos puntos que nos
dan donde se intersectan napas gráficas
para encontrar las ecuaciones de ambas
funciones
primero pensemos en la función lineal fx
igual a mx más b y nos dan dos puntos
con ellos podemos encontrar la pendiente
por lo tanto m que es la pendiente va a
ser igual al cambio en james entre
cambio en x
la tasa de cambio del eje vertical con
respecto al eje horizontal entre estos
dos puntos dime cuál es el cambio en x
vamos del x igual a menos 1 hasta x
igual a 1 podemos pensar que terminamos
en 1 y empezamos en menos 1 y que vamos
a tomarnos uno menos menos uno lo cual
es igual a 2 por lo tanto nuestro cambio
en x es de 2 y podemos verlo en nuestra
gráfica ahora cuál es el cambio
james bueno empezamos en 9 y terminamos
en 1 terminamos en 1 y empezamos en 9
entonces uno menos 9 es igual a menos 8
sólo para ser claros cuando x es igual a
1 y es igual a 1 y cuando x es igual a
menos 1 y es igual a 9 y después de
tomar estas diferencias ya podemos decir
que tenemos una pendiente de menos 8
entre 2 lo cual es igual a menos 4
entonces podemos escribir hasta ahorita
que fx es igual a menos 4x
más bien
y podemos verlo aquí cada vez que
aumentamos nuestra x en 1 y bajamos 4
unidades lo cual tiene sentido porque
tenemos una pendiente de menos 4 ahora
pensemos en cuánto vale b para obtener p
podemos usar cualquiera de estos puntos
y sustituirlos en nuestra función y
despejar a b así que usemos el segundo
porque el xl1 entonces podemos escribir
que f1 será igual a menos cuatro por uno
más b y bueno nos dicen que f 1 es igual
a 1 de esta parte de aquí podemos
escribir que menos cuatro más b es igual
a 1 y si sumamos 4 de ambos lados
obtendré que ve es igual a 5 por lo
tanto ahora sé que fx es igual a menos 4
por x + 5 y la intersección de quien es
correcta con lo que vemos en la gráfica
podemos ver que la intersección con el
eje james es 5 resolviendo para b ya
podemos estar seguros
y también podemos obtener abel usando la
pendiente que aumentamos en 1 en xy
decrecemos en 4 en 10 llegamos a una
intersección en el eje que de igual a 5
perfecto ya con esto tenemos la ecuación
de la función lineal ahora trabajemos en
la función exponencial en este caso
podemos usar estos dos puntos para
obtener ambas incógnitas a y ver si
trabajamos con el primer punto tenemos
que en que de menos uno es igual a amd
por rm elevado a la menos uno y bueno me
dicen que eso es igual a 9 ahora a por r
elevado a la menos uno es igual a entre
ever entonces puedo poner que a entre r
es igual a 9 o multiplicando de ambos
lados por r tengo que es igual a 9 veces
r ahora usemos el otro punto en el otro
punto nos dicen que gm de 1 es igual a a
por r usando la definición de la función
que es igual a 1
y ahora puede usar esta información para
obtener a
r para eso déjame bajar la pantalla
podemos tomar esta de aquí y sustituirla
en esta segunda ecuación y me quedarán
que 9 r que es lo que vale am por efe es
igual a 1,9 por el elevado al cuadrado
es igual a 1 si divido de ambos lados
entre 9 obtengo que r elevada al
cuadrado es igual a 1 entre 9 y ahora
podría tomar ambas raíces y decir que r
es más o menos algo pero no olvidemos
que arriba nos dicen que eren es mayor
que 0 por lo tanto puedo tomar la raíz
principal de ambos lados y obtengo que r
es igual a un tercio ahora puedo
sustituir este valor en cualquiera de
las dos ecuaciones originales para
obtener aa si usó la primera me queda
que es igual a nueve veces r entonces
nueve por un tercio es
3 por lo tanto a es igual a 3 y ahora si
mi función exponencial la puedo escribir
como gdx igual a amp que es 3 por erc
que es igual a un tercio esto elevado a
la equis y ya con esto tenemos ambas
funciones nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo